now to some developing news on the next
election sources close to former
president Donald Trump tells CBS News he
intends to launch his 2024 presidential
campaign tonight for Mar-A-Lago now he
has been telling his allies he plans to
move forward despite taking some heat
within the GOP over disappointing
results in the midterms Chief Washington
correspondent Major Garrett is near
Mar-A-Lago Beach or in Palm Beach
Florida excuse me uh major what's going
on
good morning Nate good morning everyone
Trump does not have to announce now even
as close as advisors acknowledge that
and they know some Republicans are
describing this preemptive move as a
sign of weakness not strength Trump
doesn't care he's decided the best way
to dominate The Narrative and not
incidentally possibly avoid indictment
is to get back on Center Stage
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement in the very next
very very very short period of time
you're going to be so happy this preview
of Coming Attractions has been going on
for months it was supposed to be
supercharged by a blockbuster Republican
midterm but for Republicans the midterms
were a flop and reviews of former
president Trump scathing there's a
significant influence from the former
president and I think that influence
probably hurt the party and and hurt the
party's chances on Election Day Donald
Trump yeah it kept saying and we're
going to be winning so much we'll get
tired of winning I'm tired of losing I
mean that's all he's done Trump must
also confront pointed criticism from
former vice president Mike Pence one of
many potential 2024 GOP Rivals do you
believe that Donald Trump should ever be
president again
David I think that's up to the American
people
but I think we'll have better choices in
the future Trump must also contend with
a new reality two Rising GOP Governors
Florida's Ron DeSantis and Virginia's
Glenn Younkin courting donors with an
eye toward denying him the nomination
Trump is expected to jump in now in a
bid to shake off the bed midterms
reassert power in the party and get a
jump on DeSantis let's say there it is
Trump at 71 Rhonda sanctimonious at 10
or any other Challenger it certainly
could make candidates move faster if
they're serious about looking at this
race Donald Trump scares a lot of people
off and he knows that Trump though
wounded retains key advantages nearly
100 million dollars in campaign funds A
devoted base of at least 30 percent in
any 2024 primary contest a full digital
operation with more than 50 million
voter contacts and support at state and
local party levels he comes into this
not just as the biggest name in the
party but with the biggest bank account
and that's certainly something he'll use
to his advantage
Trump also faces a number of legal
challenges including allegations of
mishandling classified documents and
ongoing New York attorney general's
investigation into his business
practices a Fulton County Georgia
investigation into an electoral vote
scheme there's also the subpoena from
the January 6 committee Trump defied
that subpoena on Monday and is now suing
the panel to avoid testifying Gail the
panel says it is evaluating its next
steps a lot of people evaluating we'll
see what happens tonight thank you major